- [Instructor] Worried that her parents
would shoot through her plan
to go to college in Brazil,
Marion told them after she
had already been accepted.
Now, they underlined through
and this is a little bit
of a weird thing to say.
Worried that her parents
would shoot through her plan
to go to college in Brazil.
That kind of implies that
somehow they're reading the plan,
they would read it really,
really fast somehow
or maybe they would
actually shoot something
through the actual, physical plan.
I don't know but this is a weird phrase
and the way that it said it,
it looks like she's
afraid that they would,
that they wouldn't like
her plan to go to college
so that's why she waited,
to go to college in Brazil,
so that's why she waited until
after she had been accepted
to tell them.
So shoot through seems a little bit off.
So worried that her parents
would shoot in her plan
to go to college in Brazil.
Now, that's, what does it
mean to shoot in her plan?
So that seems weird.
Worried that her parents
would shoot on her plan
to go to college.
Well, that's also, how do
you shoot on something?
Now, I guess if shoot
had a different vowel,
that might make some sense but anyway,
that would be inappropriate but anyway,
let's rule that one out.
Worried that her parents
would shoot down her plan
to go to college in Brazil,
Marion told them after she
had already been accepted.
Well, that makes all
the sense in the world.
To shoot down a plan
would be to reject it,
to say all the reasons
why it's not a good idea,
why they're not going
to allow it to happen.
So that makes complete sense
with the rest of the
context of the sentence.
So I like that a lot, shoot
down her plan to go to college.